we have to concede some ground here of
course sometimes men have gotten it
wrong when you look back for example on
some Hollywood classics I mean like
Seven Brides for Seven Brothers I'll
give you this one troop was riding by
and saw what we talked save I'm here
today to give me a wife back home
empty-handed y'all
[Music]
angry and annoyed but secretly they was
overjoyed all that went for Alan what is
it for why are we go down together
okay that one that that's one for you
yeah feminist by the way we actually
have some archived never-before-seen
footage
yeah rectory very past tag blessed all
of us here are man enough to admit when
we're wrong that's the Seven Brides for
Seven Brothers director's cut I'll I'll
admit in retrospect a little tone deaf
take a look ah gee I don't think I'm
ever gonna find a man I mean woman OH
why would you just do like the Romans
did with those sobbing woman or save I'm
woman whatever they're called now see
those Romans they were the same kind of
fix urine they were out there explore
new territories and resources were
scarce but see they had these seven
women south of town and what those
Romans do they went on down there
snatched them up and carried them off
and if you can't do better than a bunch
of old Romans well you're no brothers of
mine with the Romans weren't those the
ones are right about there set up north
of here no I'm talking about the olden
times a red bottoms friend computers
book ah book I'm talking about history
this really happened tell you about them
sobbing women who lived in the Roman
days it seems that they all went
swimming while their men were off to
gray woman troupe was riding by and saw
them in their middle miles only to come
Oh
on the dry least that's what lutar said
this song sounds a little bit rapey
rapey no you just haven't heard the rest
of the song and the women was sobbing
sobbing sobbing fit to be tied every
muscle was throbbing throbbing from that
riotous ride seems they cried and kissed
and kissed and cried all over that room
in countryside so don't forget that when
you're taking a Pryde sobbing fit to be
tied
from that riotous ride yeah no
definitely rapey no I'm really
uncomfortable with this I mean these
women clearly not even willing
participants yeah you're surfacing
original version original version all
the [ __ ] were sobbing sobbing sobbing
screaming up no papers were throbbing
throbbing throbbing ready to play Oh
Renton screaming screaming wreck while I
service myself in a potted plant she for
when she talks to the fuzz she better
keep
oh hey did you like this video of course
you did
let's there's something wrong with you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe